even though he was technically never a
comedy store comic Jerry Seinfeld can
still be added to the list of great
comedians who were made better in some
way shape or form by Mitzi Shore even in
this case where Jerry was using her
denial as motivation throughout his
career was that woman across the street
and ultimately got his revenge 10 years
later in the early 90s did you ever have
another conversation with Mitzi Shore or
did you ever convey any message to her
or have any communication I did when I
got my TV series in the 90s I moved up
to this fantastic house in the Hollywood
Hills that overlooked all of La every
day I would drive down the hill to go to
the studio to work on the show I would
see Mitzi taking her walk on a nearby
street that we happened to have in
common and I would always give her a
nice look